they matched that sense of the power of
the individual to a belief that you're
not responsible for the consequences of
your actions which is incredibly
convenient in the startup yes I guess if
you can disrupt without being
responsible for the people disrupted and
you know you cite only the first half of
the Schumpeter paragraph on creative
discretion you don't go to the rest of
the paragraph where he explains you of
course you're responsible for taking
care of all the people you disrupt I
mean that removes so much friction and
their insight about removing friction
from the startup process I mean I have
such admiration for that insight the
problem is that they were so successful
that the companies got to a scale where
they couldn't help but be responsible
for massive impact on society and the
notion that they weren't responsible was
not gonna hold up politically in fact it
was complicated in the Fayette case of
of Facebook's properties and Google's
properties by essentially having the
loudest voice in the public square in
every country in which they operate
which was the whole civilized world
essentially and especially the developed
world and European and the Americas and
in those environments when you're the
loudest voice in the public square when
you dominate politics you have
responsibilities that you cannot shirk
and when you're not elected and you're
not accountable hmm you had better
self-regulate or or you wind up with
what we wound up with which is train
wreck which is a lot of train wrecks
right and if you will trains piling up
everywhere piling up every when you look
at this quote though actually think to
dovetail into what you're saying the
might is right libertarian you know Ayn
Randian kind of Stanford PayPal mafia
world view you had Sean Parker who was
part of that my friend Sean who did
Plaxo and like really learned how to
grow things quickly you talk about that
in the book which is amazing by the way
and you read it thank you for reading it
I love when the author reads her own
book
that when you look at Zuckerberg clip
that we just played where he says listen
there's no way you can tell me that a
little bit of fake news is gonna
influence somebody's ability or swing an
election when in fact at the same time
he knowingly had teams manipulating
people's emotional states
on the platform as in a Maslow you know
Stanford experiment gone wrong and he
sits there and lies well actually and
says it's not possible but how is that
not a bold-faced lie and you know it's
not better than I do having been his
mentor in the early years how can he say
something like that when the sales team
has a deck and they're going out and
selling people on winning elections with
the platform and then he says you can't
win the election with the platform I
don't want to pretend that I know
exactly what was going on in his head
but I'll say this about mark mark is
incredibly idealistic in the sense that
he had a vision at the beginning which
was true and he was 22 the day I met him
that connecting the whole world was so
important and so positive and idea noble
noble in the most extraordinary way that
it justified whatever means were
necessary to get there and there's the
flaw because Mark really had has always
had trouble imagining people using the
platform differently than he would use
it or differently than he intended so
the idea that that somebody would try to
tip an election was just not something
he could imagine and the key thing is I
think to this day we still have not
actually surfaced the real problem here
the Russians help to get Donald Trump
nominated you know with what they did
over Facebook and what they did over
instant pretty clearly and what they did
over Twitter now in the general election
phase the theft from the Democratic
National Committee and the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee those
had a profound effect but they weren't
manipulating social media no that was
just straight-up hacking right those are
straight-up hacking has Julian Assange
Russian agent but when you
at Stephen bannon's incredible insight
that you could use Facebook to invert
politics so instead of Facebook being or
instead of politics being about
persuading the voter that your
candidates two or three big policy
objectives are the most important thing
on earth
you sit there and you find the weakest
emotional point for eg voter and you
essentially have n number of campaigns
where n is the number of voters out
there and so it's the same Truman Show
idea they apply to ideas in general
you're now applying to an election and
so if they find out that you are like
well you're passionate about Bulldogs
and they're they realize that in country
as polarized the u.s. you're not going
to move many people from Clinton to
Trump or Trump to Clinton no but what
you can do is cause people not to vote
and that is the most sinister of this
isn't it and so what happened what they
did which is unbelievably cleverest they
targeted three communities suburban
white women people of color and
idealistic young people and they would
find for each individual voter what was
the thing that most animated them and
then they would somehow find a way to
position it that both candidates were
dishonest on that issue so in your case
it would be both candidates have
Bulldogs for dinner right they have
roast bulldog that's well like Melissa
crazy
it no it's just awful just at just awful
and you certainly wouldn't want to vote
in an election I'm not going for a
bulldog killer exactly I wouldn't either
and so they both they suppress both of
our votes successfully
[Music]